our next guest is an actor
a comedian
and at times a human punching bag
you know him as johnny knoxville but to
those who are close to him
he is known as pj
he is a very loyal friend
a wonderful father
and i think that we can all agree on the
fact that he is a true pioneer
he's here to promote the latest
installment of jackass forever take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like i got a 200 pound salon oh
my
[Applause]
[Music]
sure enough luke close to the sun
fell to his doom
ladies and gentlemen
oh my god you look great oh stop it i
mean it
so a little context um johnny and i and
our dear friend spike jones we've all
known each other for many years
um we've had many fun times and hangs i
have some pictures oh there's one night
yeah yeah
sharpie mustaches yep we would burn wine
corks and and and and put and there's
you with your sharpie mustache
i remember your living room with the
pool table so well yes
you at a certain point
were asked to be on saturday night live
yes as a cast member
and it was the same time
that you were making the pilot for
jackass right
well i was really honored that lauren
michaels
offered me five minutes on the show each
week to do
what i do the videos and whatnot
and i had to choose because one thing
i was going on to an established show
where
i would have little control and at the
end of the day is like am i going to go
into a situation where i have no control
or am i going to bet on myself and
battle my friends
and
go that direction and ultimately i bet
on myself and bet on my friends which
could have been a disaster right it
could have been a disaster but luckily
it worked out and some would argue it
was still a disaster
and you were doing commercials yes yes i
did commercials as well i i was i lived
next to antoine fuqua and he helped me
get an agent you were a car washer in a
gum commercial in 1995 oh no um we have
a clip take a look
dustin this is popular chewing gum
flavor that really puts your breath on
ice
for a long
long time
oh my goodness
wow
yeah
and that's probably what i'd be doing if
there wasn't jackass you know
or who knows again you had no major
opportunities but
even making this movie now
you guys were
wavering whether to do it or not and you
got together for two days started
testing the waters and what was the
feeling well spike insisted from the
beginning when i said i wanted to do
another one and he's like
i really think we should do a test
because we're older now like we're in
our mid 40s some
50 yeah i was like mid-40s yeah yeah i
was trying to put a happy face on it um
but
he's like is it going to look sweaty
when we're doing that now
so we uh not only tested the new cast we
were testing ourselves and within an
hour of the two-day test it felt
wonderful it's like we've never stopped
and uh it was just great to have the
family back together again it's it is a
family and uh and one i have missed i
mean we're all friends outside of this
we see each other outside of this but
nothing is more uh nerve-wracking
um especially for the guys because they
don't know what's and and now uh rachel
wolfson we have a lady in the cast which
she's tougher than any of the guys
i mean it's no secret that women are
tougher than guys but she proves it over
and over in the film
yes
[Music]
you